[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
permettez que je démarre mon
intervention par une citation ci sutter
il y a trop de pauvres c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez de riches cette citation
est de jean claude rocheleau ni qui est
un entrepreneur français
je trouve cette citation édifiante et
j'essaierai de vous le démontrer tout au
long de mon intervention je suis c'est
la fin de la cua où je suis marié père
de trois enfants et je suis directeur du
crédit de l'una côté xi je viens d'avoir
vingt cinq années d'expérience au sein
de cette institution
j'ai démarré comme gérant d'une kopeck
par la suite formateur à la direction
régionale
et puis directeur régional j'ai occupé
le poste 2 inspecteur général qui
contrôle et qui correspond au poste de
directeur du contrôle interne
pendant sept ans j'ai été directeur des
ressources humaines pendant quatre ans
et depuis le 1er avril 2018
je suis le directeur du crédit de l'una
copé xi voilà pour ce qui est de mon
parcours alors je vous ai dit j'ai fait
neuf ans deux banques avant d'aller au
micro finance et pour avoir connu le
secteur des banques classiques
je peux dire aujourd'hui que le système
financier adapté aux pays de l'afrique
c'est la microfinance
vous allez certainement me demander
pourquoi tout simplement parce que la
microfinance avec ses produits donnent
accès aux plus démunis qui sont les plus
nombreux d'avoir des financements pour
réaliser leurs activités génératrices de
revenus et chaque matin lorsque je me
rends au bureau je suis certain
deux contribué à réaliser le rêve d'un
homme d'une femme d'une famille tout
entière
à titre d'exemple pas plus tard que hier
dans la journée d'aujourd'hui c'est une
dizaine de dossiers pour un montant de
100 millions de francs cfa que nous
avons octroyé à cette dizaine
d'entrepreneurs alors nous allons voir
les différents types d'institutions
financières
une institution financière et l
établissement financier qui propose des
produits financiers à ses clients
nous avons les institutions financières
les banques classiques qui connaît une
banque classique ici quelqu'un a t'il
pas un compte dans une banque classique
très bien il y a les institutions 2 mai
aux finances et les institutions de
microfinance
alors les institutions de mai aux
finances sont spécifiques aux petites et
moyennes entreprises et aux toutes
petites entreprises le financement sont
centrés sur ce type de clientèle
la maison finances est définie comme en
étant un système financier à la
frontière des banques classiques et des
institutions de microfinance
alors qu'est ce qu'une institution de
microfinance parce qu'avec cette
définition
nous allons aborder le thème de mon
intervention de cet après midi qui est
le rôle de la microfinance dans la lutte
contre la pauvreté et l'exclusion
alors qui peut me donner un exemple de
formule 1 ferme est informé par blond
qui s'apparente à la microfinance
la tontine très bien la tente il la
tontine est une forme de micro finance
et la micro finance tels que connaît
aujourd'hui
a fait son apparition dans les années
1970 plus précisément en 1978 avec la
grameen bank au bangladesh du docteur
mohammad yunus qui en est le petit soeur
il est aussi appelé le banquier des
pauvres
ben la microfinance est bien plus que ça
la microfinance ce sont des produits des
pagnes des produits de crédit des
produits d'assurance des transferts
d'argent ainsi de suite parce que quand
on parle de microfinance tout de suite
on parle on pense au microcrédit non
l'ami qu'aucune financer plus que ça
alors la reddition de ricoh finançons
des organisations très variés de par
leur statut juridique et de par leur
taille du pas leur structure ainsi de
suite il y à des institutions de
microfinance sous forme de société
anonyme des institutions de microfinance
sous forme de coopérative
il y en a même sous forme de ong alors
on trouvera le système les institutions
de micro finance en général dans les
pays d'afrique d'asie et d'amérique
latine
alors tenez vous bien en côte d'ivoire
il y à 48 institutions de microfinance
dont 30 une constitué sous forme de
coopérative et 17 constitué sous forme
de société anonyme
alors nous allons et parmi cette tente
une institution de microfinance du type
coopérative
il y à la toute première qui a été créée
en 1976
c'est l'une à copé xi d'une apoplexie
c'est l'union nationale des coopératives
d'épargné et de crédit elle a constitué
sous forme en un but à liszt la première
kopeck a été créée en 1976
à couteaux à boundiali boundiali c'est
dans le nord de la côte d'ivoire est à
ce jour l'une à côté qui compte plus de
1 million 300 mille membres sociétaires
un million trois cent mille membres à
fin octobre dernier elle a produit plus
de 38 milliards neuf cent soixante cinq
millions de francs cfa de crédits
qu'elle a injectés dans l'économie du
pays est la n1 coûts de crédit de 40 4
milliards et conformément aux principes
coopératifs
chaque membre paye une part sociale qui
fait de lui un propriétaire à part
entière de l'institution et
l'institution est sous le contrôle de
ses membres les membres de l'unat copé
qui sont de toutes les couches
socioprofessionnelles
il y à des commerçants des artisans des
planteurs des éleveurs des éleveurs et
des agriculteurs des fonctionnaires des
retraités toutes les couches sans
distinction ni d'être dit ni du race ni
de partis politiques ainsi de suite
alors comme vous le voyez l'une à côté
xi est au coeur du développement de la
côte d'ivoire
à ce jour elle compte 136 points de
vente répartis sur tout le territoire
national
c'est le réseau de microfinance le plus
étendu du pays
et l'objectif de l'unesco pecci c'est
d'être plus proche de ses membres afin
de leur proposer des produits de
proximité alors la microfinance moyens
de lutte contre la pauvreté
vous savez la micro finance s'inscrit
dans la durée par la création
d'activités génératrices de revenus
et je vais vous donner quelques exemples
d'activités qui ont un impact sur le
développement durable l'ivac au taxi
avec le cabinet de la première dame a
mis en place un projet d'autonomisation
des femmes ivoiriennes et ce sont de
petits prêts qui sont octroyés aux
femmes pour des montants qui varient de
30 milles à 500 1000 et de 2013 date du
début du projet jusqu'à octobre 2019
c'est ça soit 114 mille femmes qui ont
bénéficié de crédits pour un encours
global de 25 milliards plus dur est
singulière à côté de l'ufap si c'est à
dire le fond aux femmes de côte d'ivoire
il y a le projet agir pour les jeunes
avec l'argent sans emploi jeune la
première phase a touché 9066
bénéficiaires pour un montant de 3
milliards 7
nous avons démarré la deuxième phase
dernièrement à la faveur de la visite du
chef de l'état dans le hand ball et
c'est 500 jeunes qui ont bénéficié de
chèques d'un montant de 250 millions
alors je voudrais dit que la phase 2 va
toucher dix neuf mille cinq cents jeunes
pour un montant global de 10 milliards
et nous devons mettre en place ce volume
2 de prêt d'ici décembre 2010 9 en
janvier 2020 a pas de janvier 2020 dans
la troisième phase ii agit pour les
jeunes tenez vous bien 720 mille jeunes
qui seront touchés pour une enveloppe
globale de 50 milliards pour financer
des projets soupir
alors pour vous dire que les micro
finance dans l'une à côté xi
s'inscrivent dans une logique de
développement durable une participation
durable qui permet aux populations
vulnérables de se prendre en charge
alors au titre au niveau 2 des
engagements personnels
je vais vous citer quelques faits
marquants
c'est pas toujours facile mais on se bat
chaque jour pour donner le meilleur de
nous mêmes
je vais vous dit par exemple qu'il y à
des empreintes des emprunteurs qui au
moment du montage de leur dossier
son doux comme des agneaux même si vous
demandez l'os de la grand mère qui est
décédée il ya 60 ans ils vont le produit
mais dès qu'il bénéficie du financement
vous être leur et débit les changements
de domicile d'emprunteurs pour échapper
à l'eau recouvrement les agressions
verbales et physiques de nos acteurs de
nos collaborateurs qui vaut fait leur
mouvement sur le terrain mais nous
considérons cela comme les risques du
métier
mais à côté de ces aspects qui sont pas
favorables pour notre institution
il y a des aspects positifs qui sont
d'ailleurs les plus nombreux lorsque
vous financer une femme qui vend de la
banane braisée au bord de la route ou
une femme qui vendent de la loco ou une
femme qui vend des légumes au marché
secondaire le marché secondaire ii du
quartier et que cette femme du jour au
lendemain se retrouve propriétaire de 22
boutique de vente de payne propriétaire
de restaurant lorsque vous écoutez ces
témoignages
vous êtes fier vous avez chaud au coeur
et vous vous dites j'ai contribué à la
réussite de cette femme
lorsque les jeunes sans emploi désespéré
envisage d'aller de l'autre côté halde
allait à un bang et l'autre rive et que
ce jeu non par hasard bénéficie des
financements pour réaliser son activité
génératrice de revenus est ce gênant
devient entrepreneur et ils emploient
d'autres jeunes vous avez votre
financement a permis à quelqu'un de
prendre le risque d'aller se noyer dans
les eaux de l'océan atlantique
et quand nous entendons ces témoignages
nous nous disons tiens voilà aujourd'hui
j'ai pu faire en sorte que quelqu'un qui
était destiné à la mort parce que celui
ceux qui vont à l aventure prennent le
risque de mourir
j'ai contribué à sauver ce serait top
je voudrais qu'on retienne de mon
intervention que ce qui fait souvent
défaut dans les pays émergents comme le
note ce sont les moyens
ce ne sont pas les initiatives les
initiatives les jeunes en ont pour
lancer leur activité pour lancer une
activité génératrice de revenus
et pour répondre à ces besoins de cette
clientèle atypique les institutions de
microfinance ont mis en place des
services financiers et non financiers
pour faire face à ses juges la
microfinance est donc un moyen une voie
vers l'autonomie une voie vers
l'autonomisation du jeune
l'autonomisation de la femme
alors on
conclure que l'ensemble des services
financiers foulée par les iem f
contribuer contribuer au développement
de conditions de vie de la population
les services que saisie est même fourni
ce sont des services adaptés qui
contribue aussi au développement durable
qui a le thème de notre journée mesdames
et messieurs oser penser projet dormez
projet rêvé projet car nous sommes là
pour vous accompagner les institutions
de microfinance sont là pour vous
accompagner
parce que chacun a droit au bonheur
chacun de vous a droit au bonheur chacun
de nous a droit au bonheur je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]